chaque pays candidat il faut que l'état
de droit la justice et les valeurs
fondamentales soient respectés c'est une
priorité
ceci exclut pour l'instant une adhésion
de la turquie la turquie depuis je suis
quelques temps s'éloigne très vite de
l'union européenne n'a pas de géant
les journalistes doivent d'être trahi
dans des rédactions de pouvoir
s'exprimer librement
les journalistes ne peuvent pas se
retrouver en prison j'adresse
aujourd'hui un appui un appel aux
responsables
libérez nos journalistes et pas que les
nôtres d'insultés nous états membres nos
chefs d'état et de gouvernement les
traitant de fascistes et de l'asie
[Applaudissements]